[موسيقى]
خبر كاذب تسمح منصه فيسبوك بتداوله وتحصل
من خلاله على ارباح طائله يتسبب في مجزره
في ميانمار او حرب اثنيه في اثيوبيا او
اغتيال في مكان اخر هذا ما وثقته منظمات
دوليه مثل امنستي وهيومن رايتس واتش ورفعت
على اثره دعاوى قضائيه في اكثر من
بلد من السهل ان نفسر تاثير خطاب الكراهيه
في اشعال الفتن والحروب لكن لماذا يخفق
فيسبوك في الحد من هذا الخطاب وهل فيسبوك
عاجز حقا عن محاربه الكراهيه ام ان لمت
مارب اقتصاديه من تبني الخوارزميات
الملغومه عام
2022 نشر الصحفي الامريكي ماكس فيتشر
كتابا بعنوان ماكينه الفوضى يحلل فيه دور
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي في تحطيم العالم
حرفيا وليس المقصود تسميم اذهان الناس
واطفالهم بافكار سلبيه عاده ما ترد شركه
ميتا مالكه فيسبوك على هذه الاتهامات
بانها ترفض حذف بعض المحتوى السلبي بذري
حريه التعبير لكن الكتاب يدحض هذا الطرح
اذ يقول المؤلف ان منصات فيسبوك وتويت
ويوتيوب اخترعت ايضا الخوارزميات التي
تسوق المستخدمين سوقا الى تبني الاراء
المتطرفه وفي احيان كثيره الى ارتكاب
افعال متطرفه كذلك ويتقاطع هذا مع شكاوى
رفعها محامون افارق على مث في المحاكم
الكينيه
فيسبوك هي المنصه الاكثر اثاره للجدل بين
المنصات الشهيره التي نستعملها كثيرا في
هواتفنا لعل هذا ما يؤكده تقرير لمنظمه
العفو الدوليه امنستي نشر في سبتمبر ايلول
2022 وينسب الفضائ على التي واجهها مسلمو
ميانمار الى طمع شركه ميتا وسعيها المتهور
للربح من خلال
خوارزمياتها ورغم مطالبه المنظمه لشركه
ميتا بان تدفع تعويضات فوريه للروين عن
مسؤوليتها عن التطهير العرقي لم تستجب
الشركه لهذا الطلب حتى
الان واذا كان اثار الخوارزميات اكثر عنفا
في افريقيا وما يسمى بدول العالم الثالث
فان سكان اوروبا والامريكيتين يعانونها
ايضا ففي كندا انضم صحفي من شبكه جلوبال
نيوز عام
2019 الى مجموعه فيسبوك يديرها كنديون
فوجد انها تحرض على الاقليه المسلمه وصل
الى حد الدعوه الى
القتل
لم تحذف فيسبوك هذه المجموعه رغم تبليغ
الصحفيه عنها لاداره فيسبوك ثم حذفتها
لاحقا بعد نشر الشبكه نتائج هذا التحقيق
للراي العام وفي المانيا سر العرب بصوره
هذا الشاب السوري بجانب المستشاره السابقه
انجيلا ميركل عام
2015 اليمين الالماني رد على الصوره
بالترويج لاخبار مضلله في فيسبوك يزعم
فيها ان الشاب مسؤول عن تفجير مطار بروكسل
واشعال النار في رجل بلا ماوى في مترو
برلين تفاعل عشرات الالاف مع تلك المزاعم
التي ظلت منتشره في فيسبوك عشره اسابيع
وردت فيسبوك بانها غير ملزمه بتتبع محتوى
التشهير
وازالته
money that
ch